hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to flying house my house is
empty and I have not seen my family for
a long time how my life became such
question many question ok my memories
came flooding back to me
ok remember what's that sound fly in the
house kill ha ha ha ha ok this game oh
jeez ok alright then ah wait hang on
Jesus that music I'm turning that music
off oh my god I'm gonna add my own music
and after that let's get some relaxing
orchestrate classical music going hmm
this is much better Symphony for might
might might Entrail might might I'm
gonna destroy this [ __ ] fly is what
I'm gonna do piece of [ __ ] over here son
of uh where'd you go where'd he go
where'd he go hey hey hey what son of a
[ __ ] god damnit you hold still you
little prick come over here you want to
take it like a man you want to take it
like a woman either ones good with me
three times combo on what I got no fly
son of a [ __ ] get back here did you
land
[ __ ] you are one sturdy fly yes
oh I got him back you little ass bat you
come back here I got a chair and it's
gonna go up your bum it's gonna turn
into a big splatter on my wall that
sounded weird but you know what I mean
oh you don't know what I mean let me
show you one mine
god damn Eve someone pass
I'm not gonna get it with a small I
think I need to get a big object bungee
problem with that one is cousin ed holes
in it
son of a [ __ ] God screw it duck enough
yes yes yes suck nuts okay did it what
do I do now
what do you mean the flocked what are
you do
fine progress thousand a pass oh okay
fine I guess I'll do that okay fine I'll
get a thousand points cuz Ike's new man
oh shut up
okay I've already gotten more points
than I had before
oh okay then Babbitt's Viking over here
wow this is not holy crap I'm just
trying to get points now I'm trying to
go for the flight
a little bit son of a [ __ ] don't even
try to get out of my face I'm gonna be
oh I'm gonna be all up in your face and
just about to see oh how did that not
kill you
not that I'm ready to kill you that I'm
silly points about a little bit of
weight no get back here you slimy
dresser [ __ ] back okay fine it no go
into this one here go that buzzing is
annoying good thing I got all this
classical music that I'm listening to
right now how am I gonna be able to get
this many points
yeah some [ __ ]
oh man hey I did something a seven times
combo in points frying pan a classic
play
I'm going back in this room laser
targeted destruction bog down business
you
okay all right something's gotta give
I'm trying to break things to get points
here not necessarily working on me
I do that
did I do something god I gotta get over
a thousand points out in the hell am I
gonna get over a thousand points that
just this is new oh no I broke you don't
know huh man go out there oh [ __ ] well
that didn't help me at all under I'm not
gonna have enough stuff left actually
kill this blood oh there's another room
oh I had no idea
it's got you anyway I'm treading all I
don't have another room nothing left a
break
get you
come on yes that was the thing but I
didn't get a calm bro [ __ ]
oh nothing left up right about my
refrigerator no okay
about whatever the hell this is yeah I
got some good clothes oh damn it damn at
nine five seven you [ __ ] let's try it
again getting combos
yes that's what I'm talking about
holy [ __ ] okay wait wait wait wait
I'm angry look at me whoa is that a
knife lettuce on knife whoa what flip
how'd that happen what did I do
I'm gonna big pile up how about a big
pile of screw you
[ __ ] need to get the better combos
maybe I actually have to be making
attempts on this for flies life get the
real points crap crap crap
Mor one more [ __ ]
so difficult
there we allow the seven-time combo
flies out of the house oh come on
son of a [ __ ] huh oh I killed it
already wow I'm great at my job I did it
that's arcade mode for you I just want
to make I just wanna make a thousand
points goddamn it shut up oh come on I
was trying to build a combo god dammit
why is this so damn hard
oh okay I did that I caved in the roof
yes I did that okay I think I found out
the secret to this game yeah
the secret to this game is not to use
the F key to throw it to fling them with
your freaking head
fling it fling it good fling it [ __ ]
fling it huh flag flag it fling it then
fling a ling all over the blink ding
lung big bog flipping yeah yeah come on
you wha what is that what is this what
is this oh okay I got whatever that was
yep get back here you brick ah
get back here yeah
yeah yeah god damn it just give me the
goddamn knife yeah give give give thank
you I don't know what it does but I got
it
rip that kill you fly apparently not
okay I'll just go into the next room
then boy huh asinine [ __ ] piece of
poop yeah take some of that
oh come on [ __ ]
god damn it just [ __ ] oh you son of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you well I've run out of
things to break not out of thousand yet
son of a [ __ ] stupid a whole goddamn fo
I walked over it
Oh God for me I'm done I killed the fly
I can't get a thousand goddamn points to
save my life huh huh so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this video if you did let me
know if you didn't let me and also you
know that super secret to killing the
fly let me know that too thank you
everybody again as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
so this is gonna suck
five nights at Freddy's I will not give
up my crime to anybody's intense
concentration at all we'll admit the
variation between the speed is like very
jarring no ammo how about a little bit